j'avais 17 ou 18 ans j'ai lu ce livre
qui m'a enchanté il s'intitule les
enfants du bon dieu est alors donc
j'avais 17 ans voilà pourquoi j'ai
commencé là où nous habitons les avenues
sont profondes et calme comme des allées
de cimetières les chemins qui conduisent
de l'école militaire aux invalides
semble s'ouvrir sur des funérailles
nationales
un trottoir à l'ombre l'autre soleil ils
s'en vont entre leur platanes pétrifié
devant deux rangées de façade contenu
sans une boutique sans un cri mais une
anxiété frémissante peuple l'air c'est
l'appréhension du son des cloches le
ciel volent bas sur mon quartier
prématurément vieilli et je n'ai que 30
ans et le sang jeune ma maison s'élève
au carrefour de deux silence l'absence
de sergent de ville ajoute à la
distinction du lieu voilà c'est antoine
blondin
c'est pas mal hein oui quand vous tombez
c'était pas mal mais c'est pas mal
oui je l'avais oublié mais qu'il faudra
que je relise la fin je le lis pour une
fois vous rappelez quand vous avez écrit
ces lignes
ou est ce que vous étiez
vraisemblablement dans un café bien
alors voilà ce livre auquel je tiens
beaucoup c'est l'édition de l'oeuvre
romanesque d'antoine blondin à la table
ronde il y as et cinq romans l'europe
buissonnière les enfants du bon dieu
l'humeur vagabonde un singe en hiver et
monsieur jadis et puis un livre de
nouvelles qui s'intitule quatre saisons
avec une préface superbe de renaud
matignon et le tout je les dis publié la
table ronde
vous auriez peut-être préféré la pléiade
non pourquoi c'est beau la pléiade
mais j'ai eu beaucoup de livres de la
pléiade j'arrivais pas à les lire
entièrement car ce tte des pages
transparent très j'ai vu que quand je
les ai une page chambly g3 d'un seul
coup j'ai vu que je les confonds d un
petit peu les unes avec les autres
oui tandis que là effectivement c'est
mieux on n'a pas quel était votre
sentiment quand on vous a remis le
premier exemplaire de tous vos cinq
romans la main dans la main qu'est ce
qu'elle était mais fier jeu
annie merci à qui à l'éditeur maison
d'édition oui ouais enfin bon c'est
l'auteur qui est quand même le plus
important novès vous avez été fier se
dire quand même c'est moi blondin j'ai
fait ça comme tous ses romans où il
enfin oui oui oui oui mais on se dit
quand même que si vous aviez fait un peu
moins la fête
si vous aviez un peu moins but il n'y
aurait pas cinq romans il y aurait là
nous aurions deux volumes avec peut-être
sept ou huit romans ça n'est pas sûr car
si on va dans un café c'est pour
apprendre des choses aussi on croit
qu'on va dans un café pour boire on va
boire pour mieux connaître quelqu'un
d'autre moi je connais énormément de
gens j'en suis très content oui mais
vous dites à un certain moment
d'ailleurs qu'un intellectuel c'est
quelqu'un qui va dans les cafés pour
rencontrer ses semblables
jusque là vérité mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya beaucoup d'intellectuels en
france alors un certain nombre de plus
en plus de plus en plus sourit alors est
ce que est ce que vous comprenez ce
sentiment que j'ai mais je suis pas le
seul que nous puissions vous en vouloir
nous qui vous aimons bien mais que nous
puissions vous en vouloir un petit peu
quand même
et en vouloir beaucoup à l'alcool qui
nous a privés quand même de quelques-uns
des romans vous auriez pu vous écoutez
moi je crois avoir écrit une fois qu'on
boit pour être ensemble et que quand on
est sous on est tout seul
donc il faut essayer boire sans être
saoul il y en a qui arrivent mois
parfois pas sur les jeux wii mais non
mais n'avait pas répondu à mes questions
comprenez pourquoi certains se disent
quand même blondin il aurait mieux fait
de temps en temps d'écrire un peu plus
on aurait encore deux ou trois
chefs-d'oeuvre fashion ans et je ne
pense pas ce genre de choses
oui peu vous importe où m
eh bien je me souviens aussi c'est un
souvenir il ya vingt ans je trouvais
dans un hebdomadaire littéraire je me
souviens très bien d'avoir écrit antoine
blondin prépare actuellement un roman
intitulé le pc des maréchaux c'était la
vérité
c'était il ya vingt ans et on n'a jamais
vu ce rebond non mais je les raconte est
très souvent à des journalistes qui se
sont mis à traiter eux mêmes leurs idées
à travers mes idées à moi ce qui fait
que dans cinq six ans j'aurais 250 pages
est fait par les autres et y répond
exactement à mes pensées à moi oui mais
je ne suis pas sûr que les autres est
autant de talent que vous voilà c'est ça
qui chie jour non votre modèle alors je
vous présente les invités celui qui est
en face de vous c'est beau vieux
complice ci s'appelle pierre chany
journaliste à l'équipe pour lequel
depuis 1946 ou suivez tous les tours de
france toutes les les courses cyclistes
et vous raconter la fabuleuse histoire
du cyclisme en deux volumes aux éditions
nathan peut-être vous tardy l'un des
grandes à bande dessinée se rappelle
brouillard au pont de tolbiac et 120 rue
de la guerre d'après les romans de léo
malet et puis aussi les aventures
d'adèle blanc-sec vous connaissez adèle
blanc sec
oui blandin et tout merveilleux
personnage qui s'appelle adèle blanc-sec
note et vous avez illustré le voyage au
bout de la nuit de céline publié par
futuropolis et gallimard philippe aux
mères vêtues comme l'assiette anglaise
je vois donc journaliste à europe 1 à
l'express et donc antenne 2 pour la cité
anglaise
j'ai d'ailleurs je remercie d'ailleurs
d'être tombé malade samedi mais je sais
que vous n'étiez pas malade se
préparerait en vérité les missions les
voilà tous didier ça très bien alors
vous nous proposez franchise postale aux
éditions jean claude lattès et vous nous
présenter à votre manière qui est
inimitable comme chacun sait brève une
sélection d'albums photo michel guérin
journaliste au journal le monde et vous
ne vous venez de publier publié à la
fois par jean centre georges pompidou et
gallimard un ouvrage très illustré des
professions photo reporter jean louis
fériés professeur à l'école nationale
supérieure des arts décoratifs critique
d'art à l'hebdomadaire le point et
auteur de nombreux
ivre sur les arts sur la peinture est le
maître d'oeuvre d'un gros et très
précieuse album on verra ça tout à
l'heure laventure dollar au xxème siècle
publié par chêne hachette et puis j'en
viens au deuxième livre qui vous amène
ici
antoine blondin c'est avec pire
assouline le pire assouline vous à
interroger et ces entretiens ont été
diffusés sur france culture
et heureusement recueilli en un volume
par les éditions françois bourin ce
livre s'intitule le flâneur de la rive
gauche
vous ne l'avez jamais sur la rive droite
autrefois oui et maintenant non pourquoi
chez trop loin non figé mais café dans
le la lèvre gauche c'est vrai on apprend
bien beaucoup de choses bien entendu sur
vous dans ce petit livre on apprend par
exemple que rollin roland le danemark
était votre éditeur à la table ronde
vous enfermez deux fois dans un hôtel
pour que vous écriviez deux des romans
qui sont là mais oui c'était lesquelles
le second et le troisième comme en 2d
c'est le sait les enfants du bon dieu le
seconde et l'humeur vagabonde de 3,06
voilà tous les deux ans fermé et
pourquoi vous êtes ils ont fermé parce
qu'ils croyaient que j'avais
pratiquement finie alors ils m'expédier
dans une maison remarquable à mayenne
hélas en peine de commencer à écrire ce
qui fait que j'ai écrit mes livres en 28
battu jour 28 jours jamais plus non le
dimanche je ne fais rien le lundi
jusqu'au samedi 3 semaines après j'ai
fini mon livre à soi même et on fini oui
mais quand 28e jour il peut arriver que
vous ne venez pas tout à fait finie mais
ça fait rien je le termine n'importe
comment
c'est pas vrai ce samedi c'est pas dans
ce faux c'est faux mais l'on sait jamais
quand est ce que vous dites la vérité à
l'ange de zulte et non pas du tout alors
dans ce livre à la fin vous dit
d'ailleurs que vous dites beaucoup de
mensonges pour vous amuser mais alors on
a l'impression aussi quand on lit ce
livre parce que vous y parlez aussi de
l'alcool etc on se dit quand même que
vous êtes il n'y a pas beaucoup d'hommes
aussi doué que vous pour l'écriture et
que vous aurez passé toute votre vie à
fuir l'écriture pourquoi mais parce que
je n'aime pas ça me donne beaucoup de
mal et d'autre part je n'aime pas
tellement ce que j'ai écrit alors si
j'étais ravi à chaque fois je
n'arrêterai pas décrire cela non bon je
m'arrête vous avez fait d'innombrables
articles à l'équipe au journal l'équipe
de france j'ai fait beaucoup de près
face une centaine mais ce que là aussi
écrire dans les journaux
écrire des préfaces n'est pas un autre
moyen une autre façon de fuir son vrai
métier d'écrivain chez hbo sud chez
boeing
oui oui
on va faudra demander ça à notre ami
pierre chany oui oui car j'étais un
petit peu impressionnés de venir ici ce
soir
et puis j'ai appris qu'ils auraient
pierre c'est très important parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont le jour de ça il
a le même âge que moi aujourd'hui c'est
à dire oui vous êtes nés tous les deux
ans 22 décembre le 16 décembre alors bon
anniversaire versez y est formidable
oui alors le jeu revient à vous oui je
sais que vous allez vous esquivez mais
quand même je vous dis enfin je pose des
questions quand même le figaro ce matin
vous consacrer une demi page et heat
rush et demi page antoine blondin le
dernier des hussards ben non
comment non les hussards j'étais bernard
prend qui avait fondé sa il s'agissait
de trois personnes 4 trois personnes
n'avaient pas 4 avec 3 hilare nimier
jacques laurent et moi limiers est mort
laurent est immortel et à l'académie
ben moi je suis entre les oui donc vous
êtes le dernier alors c'est bien
pratiquement oui ils ont raison
bon est ce que c'est un ulcère selon
bernard franck vacher quelqu'un qui
serait un petit peu hostile contre les
grandes leçons comme celle de sartre par
exemple l'existentialisme et qui aurait
tendance au contraire à s'en aller un
petit peu à gauche à droite à kaka
valait 1 us à quelqu'un qui monte sur un
cheval alors nous pour bernard franc je
pense que ce sont des gens qui montait
sur des choux pour aller à gauche et à
droite
je crois ce qu'ils pensaient mais a eu
sa roue si c'est quelqu'un qui avec
insolence parle avec légèreté de choses
graves et avec gaieté de choses qui sont
tristes ça lui arrive
bv oui je vais moi même c'est aussi
votre manière sa wish hlf effrité vous
parlez beaucoup dans vos d'un solide de
vos amis on sait que l'amitié compte
beaucoup pour vous 1962 c'est la mort de
roger nimier jour en septembre
le 28 sept 28 7 ans est ce qu'on peut
dire cette mort a été terrible secousse
pour vous vous étiez sont des règles est
ce qu'on peut dire qu'il ya un blondin
avant septembre 62 et anne blondin après
septembre après la mort de nimier
pendant dix ans je n'ai pu écrit que
j'ai des articles et puis de lille non
pendant dix ans oui mais c'était
peut-être aussi que vous êtes un peu
paresseux vous avez dit que vous aimiez
pas écrire cette douleur était peut-être
aussi un prétexte
affreux mais finalement utile pour ne
pas écrire mais quand on y met et morts
il y avait dix ans qu'il n'écrivait plus
non plus moi j'écrivais encore il est
mort alors à mon tour je prenais mes 10
ans moi aussi qu'est ce que vous avez
connu un vous limiers oui mais je n'ai
toujours pas très liés on se voyait mois
que nous sommes revus par la suite je
dresse et hop ça mais sans plus mais
alors deux révélations sur votre amitié
avec nimier vous révéler que lorsqu'il
s'est tué en voiture ce n'était pas lui
qui conduisait moi j'ai longtemps cru
mais c'était là la jeune femme qui
l'accompagnait et la deuxième la
deuxième révélation c'est que il a
laissé un manuscrit qui n'était pas
terminée c'est d'artagnan amoureux oui
milk qui passait déjà à elle chaque
semaine oui il n'avait pas achevés
entièrement entièrement entièrement et
qu'avez vous fait eh bien je me suis
essayé de faire pareil pour les deux
derniers chapitres vous avez écrit les
deux derniers champions avec des notes
de lui de toute façon dont est comme si
c'était l'amitié vous fun l'amitié vous
fait écrire plutôt way ou le contraire
ouais et marcel aymé vous étiez très
amis de marcel aymé 13-13 avis qu'est ce
que parce que pourquoi aimez-vous nimier
et marcel aymé
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il y avait chez
eux qui vont d'abord nié s'entendait
bien entre eux ils m'ont pris avec eux
et tous les trois eh bien on s'entendait
remarquablement bien
et pendant un an et demi tous les
dimanches nous allions chez céline mais
on a parlé tout à l'heure
comment est-ce que ça se passait c'est
dimanche c'est céline et bien parfois
c'était exquis parfois c'était pas très
exclu mais il ne supportait pas que l'on
fume que l'on mange que l'on boit alors
c'est hier normale et y est superbe
de quoi parlez vous de tous alors lui
arrivait déjà des choses sublimes
pilote- voit des choses des gens qui
n'aimait pas beaucoup alors au bout de
1h30 on partait on allait dans le
premier bistrot ça se termine toujours
au bistrot mais il faut bien quand même
pour se dire au revoir mais est-ce que
vous causez que l'amitié c'est plus
important que l'écriture
ah oui et s coup s que l'amitié c'est
plus important que le vin blanc
s'avançant il a réponse à tout
bien des questions j'ai peut-être une
suggestion donc on peut peut-être faire
ce que son éditeur a fait pour antoine
blondin on peut peut-être tout à l'heure
comme on veut tous qu'ils qui nous
redonne un roman on peut l'enfermer six
antennes delà des gardiens tout ce qu'il
faut pour ça et dans 28 jours on revient
on va essayer wish i 28 bouteille de vin
chaud reste ça leur goûter
cynthia casse alors franchi 1 là je suis
votre homme un jeu vraiment je retiens
la commençons ce soir commençons ce soir
day tout à l'heure voilà alors je vais
vous faire de petits cadeaux offert des
cadeaux quand même pendant toute cette
émission pour remercier d'être venu
d'abord de petits cadeaux impertinent le
premier c voilà c'est la plus ma mémoire
des sergents majeur savez les sergents
majeur c'est ingérable pub est ce que
vous avez écrit avec des sergents
majeure non n'a pas écrit alors la vie
des sergents majeur n'a duré que quinze
siècles puisqu'elles ont remplacé les
plumes d'oie et après bien évidemment ça
a été le stylo à bille alors sa superbe
l'hymne fait part de food et sergent
major jean peu jean-pierre lacroux et
lionel vendent clim aux éditions ramsay
voilà c'est le premier livre que je vous
offre et puis alors maintenant elle a
comme vous dites dans votre livre que
vous ne vous n'aimez pas manger et que
d'ailleurs vous cacher quand vous mangez
pourquoi je bois devant tout le monde et
je me cache pour manger alors que tous
les gens sont là tout le contraire oui
mais pourquoi ils mangent en public et
rentrent chez eux pour voir
moi pas le on a parlé du troisième livre
antoine blondin qui s'appelle alcool de
nuit de bastide et cormier
ça ce sont des des amis avouent qu'ils
sont journalistes jeu pro parisien
libéré est qui et qui rate son quitte
plus depuis 30 ans 1
on se quitte plus oui 30 et pendant plus
de trente ans oui alors ça c'est le
récit je dirais enthousiaste et
minutieux de vos gueules de bois
oui un truc puis voilà ça c'est vraiment
alors c'est surtout à eux deux qui
écrivent mais vous avez fait un texte
d'ailleurs qui quitte
liminaires et c'est intéressant parce
qu'on y voit votre votre écriture est
absolument superbe
oui j'écris bien écrit mais très vite
j'ai écrit peu de temps a montré à un
journaliste qui nous avait commandé à un
paquet pour vsd m'a montré votre votre
manuscrit en me disant j'ai été sidéré
en effet c'est fou ce une écriture une
calligraphie on a envie de donner
l'imprimerie directement y avoir il ya
pas de correction vous raturé jamais
jamais oui je m'en souviens je pense que
ça continue si paul pas d'intérêt autour
de l'oppression il écrivait sur cahier
l'espace soyez donc ses valises à peu
près et quand il y avait de ratures 18e
ligne mais recommencer tous extrêmement
scrupuleux attendant j'aime pas ça c'est
vrai alors vous n'êtes que le bistrot
constitue un lieu privilégié pour les
vocations douce amère des paradis perdu
ce qui est très jolie vous deux jours
dans ce texte vous dit ouf fait les homo
vous dites sage surtout ça c'est
étonnant vous considérez comme les
écologistes du comptoir là les trois
lascars les écologistes du comptoir
labour fait un peu gay comme guest house
ça s'est gâché sa chaleur quelque chose
je le cite est ce texte de renaud
matignon qui ouvre la reddition de vos
livres de vos romans et il dit ceci
parle de 10,6 livre s était déjà depuis
toujours ils parlent de vous un dans ce
coeur et dans ce regard et si elle
trouvait dans ce vers quelque chose
comme sa grammaire sa syntaxe sa langue
peut-être l'inclination boisson qui font
tourner la tête d intel - une maladie de
l'organisme qu'une disposition de l'âme
une griserie à retrouver plutôt qu'à
trouver derrière ce x surmené ronge sans
doute quelques cirrhose du coeur qui
naquit d'un carnet de bar a fait un
livre d'heures c'est très beau les biens
dits oui mais c'est très bien c'est
superbe
mais est ce que c'est juste oui oui
ouais enfin oui pensé qu' il y as chez
vous au départ une disposition de l'âme
parce que finalement vous souvenez vous
on est trop malheureux parce que sur
cette terre on sait pas trop ce qu'on
fait que finalement il vaut mieux boire
entre copains pour oublier plutôt que
voilà task force trop dans le sens
inverse oui il ya ce petit livre aussi
de robert giraud les lumières du zinc
aux éditions dilettante
j'ai voulu écrire à 999 exemplaires
seulement bien il parle de vous robert
giroux un moment il parle d un gain il
parle des bistrots et vous auriez dit
ceci si j'avais tout l'argent que j'ai
dépensé au bistrot qu'est ce que je
pourrais me payer comme cuite
aujourd'hui à mâcher vrai c'est toujours
vrai toujours vrai que supposer mais
tout semble banal un peu triviale même
c'est vous buvez mais vous buvez quoi
n'importe quoi mais pas non à ces
spécifications c'est pas vrai donc oui
c'est pas vrai nom toutou mais le vin
blanc ça m'intéresse maintenant à ce que
j'ai promis après abidjan
on avait commencé avec les enfants du
bon dieu
il y à cette phrase à six et à la fin le
héros dit ceci c'est là dès les
dernières lignes j'ai lu les premières
ces dernières tout à l'heure je
m'adresserai à dieu et je lui dirais mon
dieu épargnez moi à l'avenir vos
taquineries cruel et je vous épargnerai
mes petits blasphème accordez-moi
seulement la grâce de comprendre votre
oeuvre
edmond accommoder c'est aussi ce que
vous dites adieu oui je parle bien comme
ça ils aiment ça et si je fais pas il me
rappelle pour que je lui redis une fois
encore je le pays
[Musique]